ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé de transport
monsieur le ministre le secteur
aéronautique est l'une des plus grandes
fiertés industrielles de notre pays nous
sommes aujourd'hui les seuls nations
capables de construire un avion de A à Z
grâce aux 4000 entreprises de cette
filière aéronautique et au 263000
emplois directs au total c'est plus de
100g d'affaires générés par ce secteur
cependant si notre devoir est de faire
prospérer cette belle industrie il est
aussi de notre responsabilité de prendre
soin de notre planète les connaissances
et les consciences évoluent et nos
concitoyens ont beaucoup d'attentes sur
la transition de ce secteur les Français
continuent à regarder le ciel avec Eva
émerveillement 8 sur 10 ont une très
bonne image des transports aériens mais
pour continuer à faire rêver l'avion
doit se décarboner
les acteurs du secteur ont déjà pris la
mesure de ce défi en témoigne les
engagements de l'accord de Toulouse
signé en 2022 pour un secteur neutre en
carbone à l'horizon 2050
outre l'avion hydrogène développé en
Haute-Garonne par un effort conjoint
inédit les acteurs publics et privés le
développement des safs c'est
biocarburant quasiment neutre en CO2 est
une condition indispensable au
verdissement et à l'avenir du secteur à
ce titre le projet de règlement européen
en cours de discussion porte une
ambition forte d'intégration progressive
de ces carburants monsieur le ministre
alors où certains d'entre nous
privilégie systématiquement
l'interdiction à la recherche de
solutions notre rôle est d'accompagner
avec vigueur cette transition en
défendant ce projet ambitieux à
l'échelle européenne et pesée de toutes
nos forces afin de rehausser ses
objectifs aussi pouvez-vous nous
confirmer l'attachement du Gouvernement
au développement de ces biocarburant
français conditions indispensables à
notre souveraineté onautique plus
généralement quel sera votre méthode
pour porter notre voix au niveau
européen et pour s'assurer du soutien de
cette industrie capital pour notre pays
je vous remercie je vous remercie mon
cher